today's top story dr. richard national
CEO of ashley agriculture died in his
home in Greenwich Connecticut
they are an incredibly secretive family
that have shied away from public
scrutiny usually behind layers of
publicists and carefully manage your
relationship
[Music]
i dr. richard Ashland being of sound
mind have chosen to lead my entire
fortune to my granddaughter Tatyana
Ashland where's Tatiana she's on her way
to New York I want you to do something
for me
girl is an ash that no one knows about
her we can do what we want with her
she's the key to our future you know my
grandfather left a message for me before
he died he said someone was going to
kill him he was
[Music]
you